thank you
[Music]
this one's a good one to ask you because
you got your own company with employees
and all right yeah okay so this is what
happened to this girl who moves to
Denver gets a job at the tech field and
uh she's really excited about getting
like a higher salary on her Tick Tock uh
she posts what her salary increases and
how much she makes the company sees it
and fires her
oh that's interesting is there something
in contracts where you're not supposed
to disclose how much you make and [ __ ]
like that when you sign into companies
there's things you're not supposed to
disclose but salary is not one of them I
don't think you're at least from my
understanding like in terms of
protection of salary data that actually
is more empowering for the employees to
be able to share that because they'll
understand who's being paid more and why
they're not paid more than the company
itself I know there's a lot of companies
out there that have a policy
um of like firing people or reprimanding
people for for sharing that like for me
as an employer
I don't publish like what everybody
makes but I think everybody knows what
they make and they Talk Amongst each
other and I'm okay with it yeah yeah why
do you think it's uh they don't want
that well particularly in this case the
company said they that it scared them
that somebody like her was just kind of
putting information out when I guess
they have some things that are a little
more sensitive especially in the
position she worked in with tech they're
like oh if you're just going to be post
if you have like an active social media
account we don't feel safe then talk to
her God damn no but the actual so here's
like this this other side of it too like
when covet hit like people started
realizing what their true value was and
there's a lot of people quitting and
stuff like that so actually what happens
is like at least in my opinion
especially as an accountant when people
are not allowed to share their salaries
it allows the companies to actually
artificially press down the income that
everyone makes because nobody knows yeah
so like open sharing type of like that's
shady yeah so there's actually like I
know there's something in there's like a
Labor Act or something where it's
protected that you're allowed to talk
about your salary to other employees
like you can't be uh penalized for that
so people are saying that maybe she
shared a little more than that and she's
just not saying or something and maybe
it's not because of her salary shared
thing but she shared how she got the
salary and that was a no no she was she
attacked the guy
was she planning to work for Elon Musk
was that the thing exactly he's got his
scales man he's trying to get pregnant
on the on like film Devil's Advocate too
though I also think that if she was
truly valuable she wouldn't have been
dropped like that that's true yeah yeah
because they're like dude you [ __ ]
crazy let's talk about this right
because you're genius we need you yeah
don't do that again please yeah is there
a is there like a probation or a period
let's say you hire somebody is there a
period of time where if you fire them
soon enough you don't have to do like a
severance and all this stuff so like
every state is different yeah state by
state right state by state is different
so certain states are what we call
everyone's added at will employee status
so as employees could provide two weeks
notice for whatever decide to quit for
whatever yeah employers can also fire
for whatever but there's certain
protected things that they can't fire
for or they'll get right in trouble with
the labor board because I I agree like
people shouldn't discriminate by like
race and all these things that's that's
that's that's that's just human decency
but I think people should get fired for
their smell they should get fired for
you know like smelling like caca coming
into work grooming habits yeah yeah like
too much eye boogers in the eye oh
that's nice pretty fireable that's that
that's the limit right stinky breath
breath thank you Brad especially if
you're a cashier what if you're just
like a stockroom guy like you're just
putting box of mine that doesn't matter
that doesn't matter but then I mean like
people do that dude there's people that
will [ __ ] shower for like days did
you could you understand the feeling of
hiring somebody and then finding out
that they are so active on social media
they're willing to share all these
details and you run a company that's a
little bit more like sensitive on the
info side well if I'm in the Pentagon
I'm gonna be like dude can you stop
posting Tick Tock videos about are you
think it moves in Afghanistan yeah he
just flexing
and there's the [ __ ] the string with
the head Terrace to try to take out and
like you know
[Laughter]
right now check it out
yeah yeah if I'm at if I'm work if I'm
working at Area 51 right I wouldn't want
my [ __ ] employee making a tick tock
video with one of the great aliens and
[ __ ] like that's too sensitive dude yeah
I feel like uh they just saw what she
did and was just like oh we didn't know
she was like a big mouth kind of thing
like it's probably that it's probably
that plane where they're like tattletail
ass but then on the on the other side of
it as far as I talk about people's uh
salaries in public it's like athletes we
hear that about athletes all the time we
find out what they're making for the
year the same time they find out you'll
say it's like posted for the world to
see it you understand like so like it's
definitely like the value because of
course they're gonna talk about LeBron
how much he made or Kyrie how much he's
making to stay with so-and-so team
because it's like I mean we need you so
it's like yeah I don't think it doesn't
matter you know there's a lot of uh like
tick tockers that let's say they work at
like Burger King or something and they
do like tick tocks about what they're
doing in the back and then Burger King
fires some kind of [ __ ] that's kind of
been happening a lot where like you get
into inside look at what the job is like
from one side and it goes on social
media and companies don't like that they
you know maybe that's the thing where
someone higher up was like you better
nip that in the bud you know she's gonna
start talking too much and then you get
another problem she forgot to put it in
her green circle bro she didn't put it
in the close friends she put that in the
public you know what I'm saying green
ring it you got to learn which things
are you know for the people that's close
I also think people kind of forget a
little bit to like you know like in
elementary school you learn like don't
do the things to other people you don't
want done to you so like imagine like
you had an assistant or like a
babysitter or something like would you
want them to
Tick-Tock or underwear drawer or
whatever right and it's like it's like
yeah technically it's not illegal or
it's not whatever but it's just like
it's out of bad taste yeah yeah so I
think it's kind of it's kind of that
thing where it's like yeah it's not
illegal but sometimes it's more than
that it's like the kind of in between
the lines things and if they're like a a
new tech company that got some new
proprietary thing they're gonna take to
Market or whatever I could totally see
why they're like dude we're [ __ ]
revolutionary here and you just already
like that I'm just I'm gonna snip it in
the butt right away even though it's not
illegal or whatever right I think it
kind of depends too right like what what
people do in the privacy of their own
homes is separate from what happens at
work and as long as she's not disclosing
like Trade Secrets like if you're doing
something in back when you're working
and shooting a tick tock and you're
disclosing how they're these are frozen
patties from Afghanistan or some [ __ ]
like that like I could see I could see
where the conflict is and why somebody
get fired but for somebody to do if now
if she was tick-tocking in the office
talking about here's my dance and I make
a hundred thousand dollars per year yeah
and then you're like
the cool thing is that she wasn't trying
to sue over being fired most people were
just the first thing they're gonna do
just I'm gonna sue you then but instead
she went to her old job and said can I
have my job back and they have rehired
her practical and they're cool they know
about her Tick Tock they don't give a
[ __ ] so yeah sometimes you just gotta
find companies you align with too that
align with you yeah that makes sense
that's that's true too because company
culture is different like you can have
one that's like
so relaxed like they just don't give a
damn about anything and somehow they
still stay alive like ours but then
there's other ones that are like so
strict that you feel like you're in
North Korea or they don't understand
social media perfectly so they're like
oh she's the next Edward Snowden better
fire her some companies will have you
shut all your [ __ ] down yeah you can
only have LinkedIn and it's better be
professional and all your [ __ ] I'm gonna
you better shut all that [ __ ] down you
know yeah in a way like in today's world
though I could understand like if I had
a very expensive company I would
probably be thinking that too in terms
of like how quickly your company can go
to the [ __ ] by somebody's like bad
post or by somebody like just doing
social media badly representing it the
wrong way God especially with cancer
culture because the momentum moves
against the big company right without
real evidence at all exactly it doesn't
have to go to court yeah you don't even
have to be a big company as soon as like
someone that's disgruntled says
something they're like I knew it these
[ __ ] rap bastards you know and then
people come after you
that's true crazy like I'm assuming like
as times keep changing what HR has to
keep up with in terms of contracts and
agreements that's crazy keep being
updated right yeah we're in a super
interconnected world we see so like just
on a total separate but similar type of
thing there's this popular Tick Tock of
this this lady she's like a nurse at a
hospital and she comes out and it's just
sad songs like and then the subtitles
like I just lost a patient they died or
something like that and that's that's a
really bad taste she's acting it out
she's acting it out you know that [ __ ]
how to [ __ ] set up the [ __ ] camera
and then go out of the room and then
open it and go oh that was fine that was
tough Sarah McLaughlin songs on in the
uh did you like wiping her brow she's
like with the snake no she had this big
ass like cute what's that huge like
yellow snake oh the boa constrictor yeah
and so it and so it uh it don't it died
it's so it's not funny but it's funny
because she like set the camera up and
was just like
was like squirrel so then it quickly
cuts to somebody like like obviously
mocking her where he goes like this and
you know yeah he's the kid tries to get
it has a fake snake but then goes back
and like fix the angles
dude that's so crazy yeah some people
just live and breathe social media
though that they can do that and it
doesn't even like register it doesn't
register as that's weird you know like
some people just they're so used to that
yeah they're so used to covering every
emotion they have that it's like that
skipped over because what's more
probably more important to them is the
feedback that they get through Tick Tock
in different positions right they're
like oh man you're great you're so brave
for doing that I can't believe thank you
for being a healthcare hero oh yeah
thank you so much and then they film
while they're in surgery and [ __ ] yeah
in their head they're just like man just
forget about the haters yeah just keep
doing what you're doing forget about the
haters yeah
I'm sure we're gonna see like different
lawsuits and I'm sure the lawsuits have
happened for like different things like
this and things are just keep evolving
yeah like it's just complex that's what
makes me like I'm intrigued by uh the
people that draft contracts for
companies and they're like there's
always got to change it you know yeah
that's a lot of paperwork yeah I mean
even that school's now all right like
let's say like what about is there rules
against kids doing tick tocks in class
all kids got phones they could record
their teachers you know like that's a
whole different Dynamic that we didn't
really have to deal with yeah yeah
that's true I don't even know how
they're like really like controlling the
phone situation the school nowadays
because it must be crazy yeah everybody
has a phone they all have social media
even the teacher is probably scrolling
while they're they're testing yeah
that's kind of wild yo and it's not like
you could just take phones away from
kids right because they need them for
different reasons or something
unfortunately some goes down into school
they need a phone to talk to their
people you know what I mean like damn
kids cycling team right like until like
we're I'm riding with the kids and
they're always joking about things like
this one of the kids like yeah yeah in
her test we had our phones on us and I
was like scrolling through finding
answers I'm like wow do people do that
these days like that's the best way to
cheat when I was a kid man I would make
like a little like this like a little
fortune cookie fortune put my whole
cheat sheet notes on like a little
Fortune oh yeah a Band-Aid and a
Band-Aid and like kind of slide it in
like I'm trying to read this tiny
handwriting and stuff and in the future
just let some scroll on the phone while
they're doing a test like that that's
crazy
what this the lengths we had to go
through I know I used to write it like
this
inside of the label of the box so they
don't see it till you drink and then
you're like
a good H2O
what the [ __ ] is so interesting about
that water
foreign
[Music]